we're gonna start today with a media
story I'm gonna present to you today the
epitome of right-wing media dishonesty
and distortion and it's gonna be
specifically talking about the economy
and employment numbers so last week as
often happens in the first few days of a
new month we get the jobs numbers from
the previous month
we got them late last week from June
there were totally unremarkable job
numbers for June more or less a
continuation of similar numbers that we
saw what we saw under President Obama
two hundred and thirteen thousand jobs
were added during the Obama
administration two hundred and fourteen
thousand jobs per month were added that
was during Obama's second term the
unemployment rate went up slightly to 4%
very small change I've been telling you
for years and years how the unemployment
rate is calculated it's been calculated
the same way for a very long time very
often when you have low unemployment
numbers under a Democratic president you
will see Republicans say when people
stop looking for work they're no longer
counted as unemployed so the number
doesn't mean anything and then all of a
sudden when a Republican has low
unemployment numbers Republicans seem to
completely forget that they were
critical of how that number is
formulated when it was Barack Obama or a
Democrat what we do often see
Republicans talk about when there is a
Democrat in the White House is the
number of people who were not working
sometimes this is used interchangeably
with the labor force participation rate
and I've been telling you for a year
after year after year that the raw
number of people that are working or the
raw number of people that are not
working the labor force participation
rate they are very often misleading
sometimes useless and almost 100 percent
at a time those numbers are used for
political gain by whoever is looking to
distort the reality of the economy it
communicates almost nothing about to the
about the economy to say X number of
people are working and the headline that
Drudge Report right-wing propaganda
sludge report ran when the June numbers
came out
red record 155 million employed this is
presumably the number of people with
jobs in the United States I am also
going to show you the headline from the
same website Drudge Report on March 8th
of 2013 when Barack Obama was president
the headline read eighty nine point
three million not working the number of
people not who are unemployed but people
who aren't in the labor force right so
when Drudge said eighty nine million not
working that included retired people
that included full-time college students
it included stay-at-home parents who
don't need to work because they are
well-off financially and what you need
to understand to realize how you are
being manipulated or there are attempts
to manipulate you with these numbers
remember that the population of the
United States has been going up forever
at many times in American history there
have been record numbers of people
working at the same time that you had
record numbers of people not working you
can display either number to make a
political point and case in point as I
told you a month ago maybe it was two
months ago there are also a record
number of people not working right now
just as right now we have if you believe
the numbers from Drudge Report more
people than ever working because there
are more people in the United States and
than ever before the numbers mean
nothing and following Drudge Report
right-wing media just jumped all over
this thing as if it was some miracle and
I hate to break it to them but sometimes
record numbers of people working isn't a
positive thing and I'll explain the
percentage not the number the percentage
of people over 85 years of age 85 or
older working today is very high back in
2006 before the the recession 2.6
percent of those 85 or older we're
working 2.6 percent today you have
almost twice as many people over age 85
working their part of
the victorious great economy of record
numbers of people working right well
hold on let's just think about it for a
second some people who are over age 85
were working because they want to some
people over age 85 are working because
eighty five year olds are slightly
healthier today than they were in 2006
on average although there hasn't
actually been that big of a change but
overall when you read that part of the
record number of people working is a
higher than ever rate of 85 plus
year-olds you have to think about it and
realize wait a second
there's more eighty five year olds than
ever working because they have to
because wages are stagnant because cost
of living goes up as wages are stagnant
and Pat this is how the right-wing media
spins these bogus narratives they put up
a number record 155 million working it
means nothing and it becomes the talking
point for the month of July yeah I
remember shortly after the Trump
administration began Sean Spicer was
saying that the president didn't believe
the strong jobs numbers under Obama
right but now the Trump is president he
obviously does believe them but I mean
that that was at least delivered
somewhat tongue-in-cheek I guess it's a
word of Apocrypha when he said that it
wasn't clear whether it was like a 90
percent joke or a 50 percent joke but
there was like some understanding of the
political nature of the numbers it was
the Drudge Report they're trying to
deceive you and I'm sure they succeeded
with many of us they do and
unfortunately the audience that it is
being delivered to is eating it up like
it is being just ladle fed to them and
it's it's any small amount of critical
analysis applied to that tells you that
it is merely spoon feeding nonsense to a
hungry audience that's all it is